yes he's going to welcome to this video
and yet another Indian opponent of a
life together symmetrical English in a
3g three these are the news wow that's
been a while since I studied this
yeah this is possible in those
sacrifices I don't know about this
specific position anyway I have to take
this better take it quickly is the night
uncie form at least blocks the easy
inclusive development which is cool what
is the option 22 navy i wonder if i
should play like a six queen e to 27 in
slo-mo okay please 95 days look see one
look see one is coming anyway this is
going to be not easy to claim and okay I
wonder bee bee hive does not work
shaky business if you move the Knight c3
I think we'll see aight i wonder if he
can play something like 95 that sets
good book okay so he prepares a 5m
[Music]
[Music]
if you move the night now i have b 52
support it the c-4 night 85 is certainly
possible okay but see I can take one D
tool if you move to the 93 i will take 1
c 1 yeah ok so here probably move it I
need to move the Queen empty sixes
heavily under pressure can I mean I'm
not really unhappy about giving it back
potentially i just wonder how exactly to
do it
you should see six I kind of I don't
let's do it okay I have to speed up he
might have before just to move that
worries me most taking is not a problem
i will take a couple of times and yeah
this isn't very me all that much yeah
I'm okay i believe i was i was afraid of
fun and I was afraid of the other move
this one ok so here even 94 comes into
consideration there is loopy six though
ok might still play be six actually
maybe I should've gone to the seven
simply to avoid that yeah ok this is not
good
okay 97 that's five
right so far up th not good now I should
have just kicked 927 set of 94 that
would have been a thing pretty easy this
position
I wonder why is not just playing really
there was nothing better that's
surprising because here again this is
nothing for what I think or maybe here
because would be true no time morning
I'm Jack one minute dime okay
I'm taking this check check check check
[Music]
check check whoops you mate yeah ok but
ok furthermore I don't have to take the
rope I'll night you wanna and then
taking will spring good check check
check me they're winning is a bit of a
joke but yeah I it was interesting I was
an interesting porn sack here I know
that those those porn sex are possible
that i'm not not really knowledgeable
about this particular one I don't think
I've played it too badly but he got he
got pressure for sure this one yeah this
is indeed a big problem
okay and that was his poor this was the
moment with what where he had to strike
92 so I have to cancel here and cancel
just a bit of a cold blooded move just
yeah but maybe if I cancel I wasn't
quite sure what I do if you just move
this I click here okay so be five
because this is another problem okay 95
I didn't see that one okay so this makes
it an ok position and now I did I think
I'm okay yeah okay the computer is just
omit materialistic place in five I
considered this but excelled I did not
want a given this is controlled maybe
I'm just too conservative them i was
thinking like this case but ok the
computer things like this is fine Oh got
the doorbell ring ok I think I we looked
at most of the stuff I have to stop this
sorry cut thanks for watching